au coeur de la forêt d'orléans
l'arboretum des grande brière rassemble
deux remarquables collections
c'est au pied de ce chêne bicentenaire
au centre du parc de 14 hectares que
nous avions rencontré bernard de la
rochefoucauld en septembre dernier à la
fin des années 60 lorsqu'il a acheté ce
terrain il était à l'abandon à la
découverte du chêne on s'est dit que ça
devait être une friche agricole où j'ai
fait toutes avaient poussé la nature
ayant horreur du vide et est devenu un
endroit impénétrables durant des années
le fondateur a entrepris un long travail
de défrichement à la main l'ingénieur
qui jadis érigeait des centres
commerciaux se racheta et plantes à son
premier arbre en 1973 l'arboretum
deviendra paysages et les arboretums
spécialisés qui existe et enfants
étaient uniquement conçu pour les
professionnels n'est ce pas
on n'était pas touristique du tout les
on admettait pas le public ici fait
conçu pour le public
l'oeuvre de sa vie n'aurait pas pu être
possible sans brigitte son épouse
aujourd'hui le parc rassemble sept mille
arbres et plus de 1500 espèces entretenu
son chimie il ya ici un équilibre qui
s'est produit et c'est intéressant le
pouvoir le montrer l'expliqué dire aux
personnes qui veulent faire ce genre de
choses nos expériences et en faire
profiter pour que pour que ça se
perpétue chaque semaine des bénévoles
viennent les poliques comme jacqueline
depuis 20 ans elle a vu les collections
s'enrichir c'est quand même un petit
paradis il le disait toujours monsieur
la rochefoucauld bah voilà j'espère que
maintenant il a retrouvé l'autre paradis
mais il disait toujours que la le l'art
brut homme c'était son paradis avant sa
disparition le fondateur avait légué le
site à la fondation arboretum de france
l'une de ses missions éduquer le public
à la préservation des espèces botaniques